[Music]
I'm a developer who needs to build and
deploy a simple inventory app to Google
Cloud so let's see how I can use duet
aai to be more
productive the first thing I notice is
that chatting with duet AI is available
right here in my local IDE vs code which
helps with contact
switching now I don't know much about
Google Cloud but I do know that my team
has standardized on containers so let's
see if d a can help me figure out how to
build and deploy this app in a
container I love that duet ai's response
breaks down tooling and platforms for
building and deploying containers packed
with just enough information for me to
be able to make a
decision Cloud run jumps off the page
for me in Duet AI response as I don't
want to have to manage any
infrastructure so let's go with that
since I don't know Cloud run I'd
actually love an example to use to
bootstrap and to stay in context as much
as possible let's see if duet AI can
tell me how to get a cloud run sample
using Google Cloud's IDE extension cloud
Cod and looks like we got step-by-step
instructions back from Dre AI so let's
step through
[Music]
them okay looks like I got the sample
cloned to my environment and I've landed
on a read me page that talks about
deployment but first let's see if duet
AI can help me quickly understand the
contents of the example
I know containers are often built using
a Docker file and I see one here so
let's actually asked duet AI to break it
[Music]
down by highlighting the contents of the
docker file right clicking and selecting
explain this it looks like duet AI gave
me a layer by layer breakdown of what is
in the docker file and I see that in Du
ai's response that our entry point is
actually app.py so let's jump over to
that file and see if du a can help us
understand the application
code now I know there are already
comments in the example Docker file but
I was still pretty happy with duet ai's
explanation and breakdown so let's see
if it actually can shed some light on
the Hello function in this flask
app sweet with du explanation I'm able
to quickly learn about the code in
natural language including learning
about some useful info that's stored and
environment variables that my app can
access in Cloud
[Music]
run now I want to start experimenting
with adding inventory functionality to
this template and since I know I'll need
to write logic to access inventory data
let's ask du AI for some sample
[Music]
data I gave dued a specifications that
it should be Json with two specific
attributes and Not only was du a able to
generate this data but I'm also able to
take that data from du A's chat interace
interace and add it directly to this new
file in the spirit of speeding up my
workflow now I'm wondering if du a can
actually help me write a function to
access this data directly from my flask
app I'll start by modifying my import
statements in the flas app for what I
think we might
need I read that I can use comments to
prompt do aai to generate code for me so
I'm going to paste in my requirements
highlight them and select generate
[Music]
code okay I think this is what I wanted
the route looks good we're specifying
the get method and we're returning the
inventory data using jsonify I guess the
next thing to do is test the app
out I'll test it locally first and since
there are some Cloud run environment
variables that we're accessing I
actually want to see if there's a local
emulator for cloud run let's ask du
aai yep there is now can du a tell me
how to use
it just what I needed du AI responded
with a couple clear steps to follow to
deploy to the cloud run local emulator
so let's follow
[Music]
them seems to have completed I think the
app is now running and exposed on my
local machine on port 8080 so let's open
this up with a simple
[Music]
browser and the app is up and running I
can see that the emulator has specified
the uh Cloud run environment variable to
be local which makes sense now let's see
if the code that du gave us to return
inventory data is
working and it looks good to me the last
thing I want to do is figure out how I
can actually deploy this to the cloud in
Cloud
[Music]
run and now let's follow DUI's
instructions on how to do this
[Music]
looks like I now have a public URL where
I can access the app running in the
cloud on cloud run and it looks good to
me to recap with duet AI I was able to
be incredibly productive going from idea
to deployment with a platform I was not
all too familiar with all in a matter of
minutes and without ever leaving my IDE
check out the link in the description to
learn more about how you too can be
productive in Google Cloud using duet
[Music]
AI